la bouche d'abord
étrange
[Musique]
vincent manière vous célébrer vos vingt
ans de carrière je me souviens la
première qu'on s'est rencontrés c'est
justement il ya 20 ans la première album
à l'époque vous étiez un jeune musicien
de sherbrooke avec une coupe me
champignons me longueuil et votre photo
est votre plan b c'était de devenir
enseignant
comment vous expliquez que vous n'avez
jamais utilisé finalement le plan b mais
c'est pas un plan b c'était mon plan
mostow d'aller à l'école à l'université
parce que puisse être parce que quand
même ce premier album les sorties
plusieurs journalistes me disais ça en
fait si tu fais pas de ce fait pas de
musique tu vas pouvoir enseigner puis le
jura dix fosses absolument être ni un
jour tu pourrais 30 ans à jusqu'à ce que
j'aille à l'école
c'est ainsi que l'accueil a été des
années fantastiques j'ai vraiment
vraiment aimé ces années là c'était de
combiner les deux géants gardera un bon
souvenir dans mes deux premiers albums
ont été faits pendant qu'il était à
l'université de sherbrooke
j'ai une vieille connaissance d'un père
vous aimez les rolling stones lors des
mêmes primes la traverse
j'adore votre chandail des bandes avec
bob dylan the music man oui oui
énormément dessus
depuis c'est cette passion le pour la
musique pour le rock and roll c'est
vraiment mener à l'adolescence
secondaire 2 3 premiers en guise
l'histoire classique la découverte des
beatles puis apprécier des stands puis
de niang et compagnie et aussi de la
chanson québécois en ca quand j'ai
commencé c'était les premiers albums de
bélanger de jean leloup puis la
découverte de la chanson québécoise des
années 60 70
pas de cet avis
vous riffs de guitare se transforme
souvent en vert doré comment vous
composez comment ça fonctionne dans
votre tête lorsque vous avez un
instrument alors devant une bonne
question observe souvent lorsque ce que
je fais c'est que je me réveille je
m'assois piégeux avec jean papier et un
crayon et je promets que tant pis gigas
et je ne joue pas d'autres termes qu'est
ce puis éventuellement ça devient
quelque chose mais toujours un moment de
suzy à cette journée où il se passe quoi
il se passera rien puis finalement c'est
sûr qu'ils y en a qui viennent et puis
où il ya une idée pile au dessus au
matin du nord demain
sa chambre est unique
ce serait
c'est vraiment sur la méthode j'avais
mathon à 14 15 16 ans puissent à ses
matons serre continuent à se définir au
fil des années mais c'est resté le même
mystère pour moi c'est resté le même
buzz vous avez beaucoup chanté le voyage
en 2003 vous avez une chanson que c'est
une seule ok on part en 2006
je pars à pied vous aimez ce à partir
mais ça va dire mais je suis parti
beaucoup dans ces années là aussi toutes
ces années là deux des années 2000 à
2010 et même jusqu'à aujourd'hui à
passer beaucoup beaucoup de temps sur la
route et ça a marqué nécessairement
l'écriture l'écriture de mes chansons
toujours aussi les artistes que j'aime
ont ils ont beaucoup chanté et chanter
la route
et puis ben l'amérique c'est quand même
beaucoup souri le québec c'est beaucoup
ce 11 mai encore au travers des doutes
des travaux
la route est de plus en plus fort votre
plus gros succès sans aucun doute la
chanson on va s'aimer encore comment on
vit dans la lumière d'une aussi grande
chanson je me trouve privilégié d'avoir
vécu sorti une chanson qui a connu un
succès aussi aussi grand puisse une
chanson qui me sont encore à peu près
dans toutes les représentations que je
fais je l'interprète avec autant de
autant de plaisir ah oui on est vraiment
sur place pour non non vraiment pas je
me suis jamais je ne me rappelle pas
d'une soirée pizza ça me tente pas de la
france au grand jamais c'était pas
tentant parfois de faire une chanson
qu'il ressemblerait beaucoup à ceux là
n'ont jamais pensé à ça mais j'étais
surtout que je me rappelle ce type de
chanson les chansons d'amour ça a été
relativement longs dans mon parcours
avant que je commence à en écrire parce
que bon moi je trouvais ça quétaine et
racoleur comme l'idée d'écrire des
chansons sur la famille sur les enfants
je me dis je ferais jamais ça
puis j'ai juste passé par toutes ces
étapes le avec avec beaucoup de plaisir
mais aussi dans avec unis toujours une
part de doute qu'ils vont habiter ici
parce que c'est des thèmes qui peuvent
être évidemment des lieux des lieux
communs c'est de trouver notre angle
notre notre signature notre façon de le
dire notre façon de fois c'est une
démarche pas un centime
vincent vallières merci de vous casser
beaucoup quelques heures à marjah et
semer en asie
[Musique]
oui